Elena says hey Ben if you had to pick a
single moment or a period of time that
profoundly impacted your life
what would it be well I honestly believe
I haven't been alive very long I'm only
33 so I believe that there have been
several you know kind of key periods of
my life I would say that one of one of
those key periods was when I was growing
up and I went to middle school I went to
public school and I was viciously
bullied there and then I was viciously
bullied in high school I think that's a
it's not a good thing that it happened
but it's a character building exercise
you have to grow a thick skin and you
have to learn that the world is not your
friend and they're gonna have to make
your own way and so I think that was a
deeply upsetting but but valuable
experience to me
Harvard Law School is a great place to
learn how to argue and learn how to
think I think that the last year and a
half has been a really tremendous
character-building experience and and
has changed my thought process he's
really interesting the other day and
somebody wrote a column criticizing me
and talking about a column I wrote in
2007 about the about dissenters from the
Iraq war they're a bunch of Democrats at
the time like dick Durbin who were
talking about how they were glad that
America was basically losing the war in
Iraq and I said this was traitorous
essentially and in a column I even said
that we should Rhian it we should
revivify the alien sedition and not the
alien Sedition Acts the Espionage Act
from 1917 under Woodrow Wilson I feel
and then Barack Obama became president
and you become the dissent and then you
realize well you're going to have to
have a certain standard it's easy to be
the people in power and it's hard to be
the people out of power and then during
this election cycle the question was
were you going to maintain that standard
now that you had the possibility of
power again and I think the answer is
that if you're not learning throughout
your life and changing how you feel
based on new evidence not based on new
feelings but based on new evidence then
you're not doing the right job I wish I
hadn't written that 2007 column Alex I
don't think that's right I don't think
that the the Espionage Act should be
revivified against people even people
who say egregious things about war and
and you know say things that harm the
war effort and I think put the troops in
a bad position free speech is valuable
because you can end up on the wrong side
of it so there are certain areas in
America in in life where I've changed my
position because new evidence has been
presented to me that I had not
experienced before the Obama
administration changed my way of thought
the Bush administration changed my way
of thought the Trump administration
changes my way of thought if you're not
changing your way of thought based on
new evidence then you've stopped
thinking and you've become rigid and
sort of blocked in